يعني بعض التفاصيل لازم ننتبه عليها اذا
بدنا نسبح في قلبي حار خلال الصيف حتى ما
نتعرض لاي هجمات من سمك القرش المجوهرات
الساعات البراقه الملابس الكثيفه كثيره
الالوان ابتعد عنها عندما تفكر بنزول الى
البحر في المره القادمه هي مجموعه من
الامور التي تجذب الاسماك المفترسه هذا ما
نصحت به محافظه الغردقه لتجنب الهجمات
هجمات الاسماك القاتله المحافظه طالبت
ايضا رواد الشواطئ وهواه السباحه بعدم
استخدام مزيلات
العرقيم
ات الاول والمكياج لانها تثير فضول القرش
كما طالبت بعدم سكب مشروبات في مياه البحر
لان اسماك القرش لها حاسه شم قويه وتزداد
اذا كانت جائعه وتبحث عن فريسه لا تكن انت
الفريسه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات